[Musique]
drunk qui signifie ivre est un film qui
peut vous enivrer d'abord vous allez
quitter le confinement est partie au
danemark
là vous allez rencontrer quatre amis
tous professeurs dans le secondaire et
chacun va tester la théorie selon
laquelle on améliore sa vie avec 0,5
gramme d'alcool de plus dans le sens
drunk est une comédie avec un formidable
voter dans un cours d'histoire
et puis le ton change et on se ressaisit
à la fin sur le plan esthétique c'est
très soignée s'est posée et puis sur le
plan du message c'est évidemment que
l'on se détournent des faux remède pour
s'ouvrir à la vraie vie au final on
termine par une danse de joie
magnifiquement interprété par matt smith
lcen qui a reçu au festival de san
sebastian le prix d'interprétation avec
ses trois autres collègues
ce film a été sélectionné à cannes il
n'a pas pu être projetées là bas c'est
le moment de se rattraper
[Musique]